problema número 185 los autos xy viajan
por una carretera el auto x recorre 80
kilómetros en dos horas y el auto y
viaja el doble de rápido que el auto x
cuánto tiempo tardó el auto y en es
decir el mismo recorrido los datos que
nos dan son el auto x viaja a 80
kilómetros
a dos horas
o lo que es lo mismo viaja a 40
kilómetros por hora y el auto y viaja al
doble de lo que viaje el auto x viaja a
1.5 de lo que viaje el auto x que es 40
kilómetros por hora
esto es igual a 60 kilómetros por hora y
ahora vamos a usar la fórmula de
distancia igual la rapidez por tiempo
distancia igual la rapidez por el tiempo
tenemos la distancia que es de 80
kilómetros
tenemos la rapidez que es de 60
kilómetros por hora
estos son 80 km y queremos conocer el
tiempo despejamos el tiempo y nos va a
quedar que es igual a 80 entre 60
esto es igual
cuatro tercios
de hora y cuatro tercios de ahora si vas
a una hora y un tercio de hora
esta es mi opción c siguiente problema
problema número 186 si el promedio de
cuatro números cada dos camas 33 k menos
55 camas 163 cuál es el valor de acá
pues vamos a hacer el promedio de estos
números
el siguiente número dos camas 3 2
las 3
más el siguiente número 3 k menos 53
menos 5 más el último número 5 camas
sólo 5 más 1
todo esto entre 4 porque queremos
encontrar el promedio de estos cuatro
números bueno que va a ser igual vamos a
simplificar esto de arriba tenemos acá
más 2 ca 3 k más 36 cada 5 k son 11 las
tres menos 5 es menos 2 menos dos más
uno es igual a menos uno entre cuatro y
nos dicen que esto es igual a 63 nos
están diciendo que esto vale el promedio
ahora con esta ecuación pues vamos a
encontrar a despejar acá multiplicamos
todo por 4 y nos quedan once caminos uno
es igual a 252 sumamos uno en ambos
lados 11 acá igual a 253 y ahora
dividido todo entre 11 acá es igual a
253 entre 11
vamos a hacer esta división por acá 253
entre 11 veamos
22 por 11 22 25 22 queda 3 bajo este 23
y se multiplicó 3 por 11 me va a dar 33
me da una división exacta así que acá va
a valer 23 que es mi opción d
siguiente problemas
si te es una entero paz y q es un entero
impar cuál de las siguientes debe ser un
número impar
paz
es impar
por definición si multiplicamos un par
por un impar
el resultado será par así que por q no
es impar si sumamos un par
es un impar
va a ser igual a un número impar impar
busque la opción c es 2
mas q y esta es la opción que nos
interesa en la opción c ya que este p es
para dos por un número par por un número
impar no importados por algo va a
convertir el resultado en un par
pero sin paz y si sumamos un impar a
algún par nos va a dar un número impar
que es lo que nos están preguntando
incluso podemos probarlo digamos que un
p
estapé es igual a 2 k otro número pero
que es paz no sé qué número sea pero es
par
es igual a 12 + 1 asegurándome que sea
siempre impar como simplificamos esto
bueno si tenemos aquí los sustituimos 2
por 2 cada que es nuestra pe más cool
que es 2 m 1 va a ser igual a 4 k más 2
m más uno
a estos se vuelven pares estas partes y
esta parte pero como siempre estamos
agregando un 1 el resultado siempre será
impar de ahí está la demostración de que
esta es nuestra opción correcta veamos
el siguiente problema problema número
188 el barril x está medio lleno de
aceite y el barril ya que tiene el doble
de capacidad que x está dos terceras
partes llena si todo el aceite del
barril x se vacía al barril y en qué
fracción estará lleno el barril x está a
la mitad medio lleno
ya se encuentra ahorita a dos terceras
partes de ella
y la capacidad de i es igual al doble de
la de x e incapacidad capacidad
si invertimos la mitad de x vamos a
contribuir para llenarlo una cuarta
parte la capacidad
de x es igual a la mitad
de la capacidad de ella
la mitad de la capacidad de x va a ser
igual a una cuarta parte de la capacidad
de y vamos a sumar esto como fracciones
dos tercios más un cuarto es igual la
común denominador es 12 4 por 3 12 4 por
2 8 más en 3 por 4 12 3 por 1 383 es
igual a 11 entre 12 11 12 ambos que es
mi opción c
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 189 si x es mayor que 0 de x 150
x entre 25 qué porcentaje de x será el
resultado vamos a hacer la operación x
entre 50 más x entre 25 entre 25 el
común denominador es 50 así que esta x
queda igual esta otra la multiplicamos
por 2 nos queda 2x igual a 13 x entre 50
y esto es lo mismo a tener 350 vos de
equis y si lo queremos como porcentaje
vamos a multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por 2
esto nos queda digo para tener sobre 100
nos va a quedar 6 entre 100 de equis que
es lo mismo a punto cero 6x o el 6% de
equis que es la opción
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo